salut il y a une chose qui change pas
tellement avec les années c'est la
psychologie des êtres humains le service
marketing des grosses sociétés
connaissent ça parfaitement l'impact des
publicicité si fort que les sociétés
mettent plus de 20 % de leur chiffre
d'affaires dans le pôle communication et
en soit c'est pas mal de communiquer de
donner des éléments factuels pour
convaincre que son produit est le bon en
tout cas qui mérite l'attention des gens
vous avez peut-être compris j'aimerais
vous proposer une nouvelle série de
vidéos sur les levier psychologique
utilisé dans la publicité ça ça va
dépendre de vos retours sur cette vidéo
et on va être honnête du nom de vue de
la vidéo parce que ça reste un bon
indicateur sur l'intérêt que vous y
portez on commence cette potentielle
série doucement avec cinq techniques de
manipulation qui font partie des plus
courantes et une collaboration
commerciale garantie centrée sur les
données plutôt que sur les sentiments
mais avant de vous en dire plus
laissez-moi vous informer que cette
vidéo est sponsorisée par Odou je vous
ai parlé de plusieurs fois cette année
et je voudrais au passage les remercier
d'avoir soutenu la chaîne pendant toute
l'année 2023 Odou c'est un logiciel tout
en un qui offre un éventail
d'application pour les entrepreneurs et
les PME gestion relation clients vente
marketing gestion RH comptabilité et
bien plus encore bref Odou c'est une
solution modulable qui vous permet une
facilité de gestion en fonction de vos
besoins vous avez en plus besoin d'un
site web bah ça tombe bien je suis
devenu un grand spécialiste on dirait je
plaisante mais Odo propose aussi une
application d'édition de site web afin
de permettre à tout le monde de créer un
site web moderne en quelques clics le
tout gratuitement car la première
application est offerte à vie la
plateforme est simple d'utilisation il
suffit de drag and drop des blocs c'est
tout et ensuite il vous reste plus qu'à
personnaliser votre site en modifiant le
texte les couleurs les images la grille
une mise en page intuitive des éléments
de votre page Web vous déplacez
facilement le texte ou les images afin
d'harmoniser le tout et si vous êtes en
manque d'inspiration sachez que Odou
vous propose même de configurer votre
site avec l'a et là c'est magique vous
pouvez générer du texte ou reformuler
des paragraphes en quelques clics libre
à vous de retoucher le texte pour
ajouter des détails si vous voulez en
savoir plus sur la création de site web
avec od dou mais aussi sur les autres
services qui proposent c'est la force de
dou je vous ai mis un lien dans la
description technique une la jalousie
alors la technique est très simple au
lieu de parler des avantages du produit
on va sélectionner la cible du produit à
qui ça correspond plutôt un homme une
femme quel âge et cetera on prend
ensuite des comédiens et des comédiennes
qui correspondent à la cible pour les
montrer heureux épanoui mais surtout on
va montrer des qualités annexes ils sont
beaux ils sont forts ils sont
intelligents ils sont respectés ils sont
aimés de leurs amis de leur famille de
quoi comparer sa propre vie et provoquer
un sentiment de jalousie la jalousie
c'est un des piliers fondamentals d'une
publicité qui fait vendre le pire et
c'est souvent le cas avec les publicités
c'est qu'on peut en avoir conscience
mais que ça agisse quand même de toute
manière d'une manière générale la pub on
se dit ça marche pas sur moi et s'il
dépense des milliards tous les ans
dedans et c'est que ça marche un exemple
dans le secteur automobile il est très
courant de voir un homme qui regarde une
superbe berline passer devant lui au
point qu'il s'arrête de marcher et il
s'arrête en plein milieu du trottoir et
là on voit un homme avec du charisme à
l'intérieur de la voiture et on vous
montre qui vous êtes vous êtes celui qui
bave de jalousie devant la voiture et on
vous montre qui vous pourriez être si
vous achetiez cette voiture l'homme
charismatique qui fait des enieux le but
c'est de stimuler ce que les
psychologues app appelle la comparaison
sociale le principe est simple l'humain
est un être avide de supériorité il va
vouloir toujours avoir mieux que les
autres êtres humains la comparaison
sociale permet de comparer les
similitudes ou les différences entre soi
et avec une autre personne pour
déterminer sa propre valeur et c'est le
psychologue fesinger qui a développé
cette théorie en 1954 il a découvert que
l'homme ne pouvait pas s'empêcher de se
comparer à plus beau que soi plus riche
plus intelligent plus tout en fait ce
qui entraîne forcément un sentiment
d'infériorité qui vient nous dire je
suis moins bien que cette personne et là
c'est qui tout dou soit la personne elle
va rentrer en mode compétiteur c'est
elle va se challenger pour obtenir tout
ce qui lui manque ou du moins tout ce
qu'elle croit qu' lui manque pour avoir
de la valeur mais à l'inverse si ce
point de comparaison est trop difficile
à atteindre ça peut créer une
dévalorisation de soi une perte de
motivation complète et ça c'est ce qui
arrive aux personnes qui comparent
beaucoup trop leur vie avec celle des
influenceurs sur les réseaux sociaux par
exemple et qui se retrouvent à déprimer
alors qu'en fait tout va bien aux
États-Unis ils ont poussé cette
technique à l'extrême vous êtes pas prêt
des sociétés de marketing embuchent des
comédien pour qu'il joue une véritable
famille dans la vraie vie donc la
famille elle est généralement composée
d'un couple de parents avec deux
adolescents un garçon et une fille et
ensuite ils mettent cette fausse famille
dans un super quartier un petit peu à la
desperérate housewife avec une super
baraque et et les enfants vont vraiment
aller à l'école les parents vont
vraiment avoir un vrai métier je veux
dire les les voisins ne savent pas que
c'est une fausse famille et dans leur
super maison il y a tout ce qui existe
de mieux en terme d'équipement en
passant par la voiture le four les
rideaux même les vêtements qu'il pent
c'est pour mettre en avant une marque et
le but c'est qu'ils rendent jaloux tous
leurs voisins pour qu'ils aient envie
d'avoir la même chose et les mêmes
marques il y a un film qui a été fait
là-dessus qui s'appelle la famine Jones
vraiment je vous conseille ce film le
réalisateur derid Bort a a vraiment tiré
le fil de cette manipulation jusqu'au
bout en montrant évidemment les dérives
de cette technique et c'est par loin
très loin si ça vous tente on pourrait
faire un épisode complet sur ce sujet-là
mais pour l'instant on va passer à la
deuxième technique la congruence
programme publicité mise en situation
vous vous promenez dans un supermarché à
la recherche de la bouteille de soda que
vous achetez habituellement mais cette
fois votre regard est dévié sur une
autre bouteille tiens c'est marrant ce
logo ça me rappelle quelque chose quoi
je sais pas oh ben tiens je vais la
prendre ça va changer vous sortez du
magasin avec cette bouteille et vous
vous posez encore la question de où
est-ce que j'ai vu ce logo déjà cette
marque de soda vous l'avez vu dans une
pub mais comment ça se fait que votre
cerveau s'en soit rappelé deune manière
inconsciente c'est l'effet de la
concruence programme publicité le soir
vous attendez de regarder un film en
regardant des pages de pub vous voyez la
pub de cette fameuse bouteille de soda
mais vous faites pas vraiment gaffe je
veux dire la pub elle passe et puis
c'est tout et là dans la première scène
du film on voit un des personnages
principals voir un soda qui ressemble à
celui de la pub et ça c'est ce qu'on
appelle un placement de produit pas la
collaboration commerciale que vous avez
eu pour Odou au début de la vidéo
placement de produit dans un film ou
dans une série c'est souvent les
comédiens qui utilise un produit et vous
savez pas que la production a été payée
en fait pour utiliser ces produits en
tout cas quand le comédien boit la
bouteille de soda vous y prêtez aucune
attention particulière mais votre
mémoire a bel et bien été sollicitée la
congruence programme publicité consiste
a diffusé un programme en relation avec
les pages publicitaires qui sont passées
juste avant pour l'implanter dans le
cerveau du téléspectateur et surtout
pour implanter les souvenir de la marque
je sors pas ça de mon chapeau le
psychologue Adrien Furman a fait une
expérience édifiante sur ce sujet il a
fait visionner à 79 volontaires un
feuilleton télévisé avec une pub pour de
la bière pour certains la pub était
avant le feuilleton et pour les autres
elle était après le feuilleton vous
voyez où je vais envenir évidemment que
dans le feuilleton vous voyez des
personnes en train de boire cette bière
en plus dans une ambiance festive et
suite à ça ils sont pas au courant hein
de l'étude qui réalise dans un
questionnaire on leur a demandé de
répondre à une question sur la marque de
cette bière afin d'évaluer leur niveau
de mémorisation il leur été demandé
quelle était la couleur du logo le nom
de la bière le prix et cetera les
résultats sont incroyables les
volontaires qui avaient vu la publicité
avant le feuilleton avaient très bien
mémorisé le produit et en plus avait une
intention de l'acheter et les
volontaires qui ont vu la pub après le
feuilleton avaient vite fait un bac
souvenir de la bière il savaient pas
bien la décrire ils avaient aucune
intention de l'acheter donc voir une pub
avant une série génère une image mentale
ment et le fait de la revoir dans la
série réactive cette image mentale au
point de créer ce qu'on appelle un
ancrage nésique troisième technique
mettre vos sentiments à l'épreuve il y a
pas mal d'années le gouvernement a
diffusé des spots publicitaires dans le
cadre d'une campagne de sécurité
routière je je sais pas si vous vous en
rappelez les images elles étaient
vraiment gore très choquantes limite
insoutenable au début je pensais vous en
montrer là dans la vidéo mais c'est
tellement trigger que je vous laisse le
soin si vous le souhaitez d'aller les
chercher de toute manière à chaque fois
les images montrent des accidents de la
route morbides donc avec des morts ou
des accidenté très grave bien sûr le
spectateur est très choqué et puis
ensuite deux pages de pub plus loin
après une pub sur un produit vaisselle
ou sur un soda par exemple qu'est-ce
qu'on voit arriver une pub sur le
dernier 44 d'une grande marque de
voiture une voiture qui a toutes les
dernières technologies pour vous assurer
une tenue de route irréprochable un
limitateur de vitesse facile
d'utilisation des caméras avant arrière
tout pour rouler en toute sécurité et là
vous l'aurez compris l'effet rechercher
est très simple sensibiliser le
téléspectateur sur les dangers de la
route et lui offrir sur un plateau
quelques secondes plus tard
la solution au problème alors on
s'entend bien à la base c'est pas la
sécurité routière qui a créé ça c'est au
contraire ceux qui vendent les voitures
qui profite du message de la sécurité
routière pour que leur pub soit placé
deux trois pubs après celle de la
sécurité routière je suis à peu près sûr
que la phrase roul en toute sécurité
mais vous l'avez déjà entendu dans une
pub une image apaisante douce sereine ça
doit vous parler pour vous prouver cet
effet d'amorçage cognitif deux
psychologues de l'Université de seou ont
fait une expérience au groupe a ils ont
montré des images choc comme cell que je
viens vous décrire et puis un peu plus
loin dans ce qu'ils ont visionné ils ont
vu la pub pour le fameux 44 au groupe B
ils ont vu quelques images un peu
documentaire sur le pétrole et la
pollution et ensuite quelques autres
trucs et pareil une pub pour le 4x4
suite à ça les deux groupes ont répondu
à un questionnaire pour savoir si oui ou
non ils avaient envie d'acheter un 4x4
un jour le groupe a qui avait vu les
images très choquantes ont manifesté la
ferme intention d'acheter le 44 alors
forcément ils ont retenu que le fait que
le 44 allait les mettre en sécurité à
l'abri d'un accident comme celui qu'ils
avaient vu le groupe B qui avait vu le
documentaire sur la pollution a
manifesté la ferme intention de ne
jamais acheter de 44 parce qu'il
craignait de participer davantage à la
pollution vous remarquerez donc que dans
les deux cas on touche au sens vital
parce que dans les deux cas on peut
mourir on peut mourir d'un accident de
voiture mais on peut aussi mourir d'une
planète trop polluée sur le long terme
et là dès qu'on touche au vital le
cerveau se laisse très vite manipuler
déjà la 4e technique de base jouer avec
l'égocentrisme du spectateur si vous
savez le fameux fr to de cette célèbre
marque de cosmétique pensez à vous
prenez soin de vous rendez-vous beau
rendez-vous attractif en achetant nos
produits de luxe par contre au cours
d'une expérience il a été montré que
l'argent avait pour effet de rendre les
cobailes plus solitaires plus
égocentriques c'est un peu le mythe de
l'homme riche et seul mais c'est
peut-être pas tellement un mythe au
final lors de l'expérience on avait deux
groupes de volontaires encore une fois
le groupe a devait regarder des images
dans lequel on pouvait apercevoir des
symboles et des signes de richesse par
exemple des billets de banque des objets
luxueux des bijoux des lingots d'or ce
genre de chose le groupe B devait
regarder les mêmes images mais sur ces
imagesl il y avait pas les signes de
richesse en plus suite à ça ils ont fait
deux expériences la première c'est que
les deux groupes devaient aller dans une
salle d'attente où se trouvaient déjà
d'autres personnes le groupe a qui avait
visionné les symboles de richesse se
sont mis à l'écart des autres tandis que
le groupe B n'a pas eu de problème à
s'asseoir à côté de ceux qui étaient
déjà présents donc déjà là on montre que
la notion d'argent a quand même tendance
à isoler on se met à l'écart du groupe
on se la joue un peu solo mais tout se
décante dans la deuxième expérience
suite à ça les volontaires devait sortir
du bâtiment en passant par un couloir et
dans ce couloir vous connaissez
peut-être un homme devait faire tomber
son poids crrayon pour observer la
réaction des deux groupes le groupe a
qui a vu les symboles de richesse ne
l'ont pas aidé à ramasser ces crayons
tandis que la plupart des gens du groupe
B lui sont venus en aide autrement dit
la richesse invite à penser à soi
d'abord à soi et rien qu'à soi du coup
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait les
publicitaires et bien ils ont mis des
symboles de richesse un peu partout pour
encourager le spectateur à penser à lui
et donc à s'offrir des produits ne
visant que son propre bien-être on peut
d'ailleurs voir le mot publicité
s'affiché sur l'écran dans la couleur or
par exemple pour préparer le cerveau aux
spots publicitaires qui vont venir
répondre à ce besoin de penser à soi et
de prendre soin de soi vous pouvez être
presque sûr que dans la majorité des cas
on aura des produits de cosmétique pour
être plus jeune plus mince ou simplement
plus beau 5e technique de manipulation
psychologique le conditionnement
associatif voilà une technique très
répondue je vais vous donner un exemple
très simple quand vous faites les
boutiques vous avez déjà remarqué il y a
toujours de la musique selon les
enseignes on peut même entendre des
tubes du moment où des chansons très
populaires en tout cas vous conviendrez
avec moi on entend rarement des musiques
comme du métal des champs régionaux des
choses un petit peu plus spécifiqu alors
ces musiques on les entend sans les
entendre donc c'est pas pour mettre de
l'ambiance dans le magasin plus on
mettra une musique qui vous plaît plus
vous allez associer le produit à quelqu
chose que vous aimez parce que la
musique vous plaît donc vous êtes dans
une meilleure disposition pour mesurer
l'impact de la musique on a présenté à
223 volontaires des stylos identiques de
coloris différents l'un est bleu l'autre
est beige quand un volontaire essayie le
stylo bleu on diffusait dans la pièce
une musique hou un peu dissonante pour
une oreille occidentale et quand un
volontaire essayit le stylo beige on
diffusait une musique populaire assez
entraînante ensuite on a distribuer au
volontaires un questionnaire afin de
savoir quel stylo il voulait acheter sur
les deux et quelle somme il serait prêt
à dépenser pour l'avoir l'extrême
majorité des volontaires ont préférit le
stylo beige et se montrer prêt à
investir dans cet objet en revanche très
peu de volontaires ont choisi le stylo
bleu alors là vous allez me dire oui bah
c'est peut-être juste parce que le beige
était plus joli alors pour confirmer
cette étude l'expérience a tenté
l'inverse c'est ils on rerser les
musiques et les stylos et c'est toujours
le stylo utilisé avec un fond de musique
populaire sympa entraînante qui a
augmenté ses vents là je vous ai parlé
de C techniques de manipulation mais il
y en a encore beaucoup d'autres il y a
aussi la sympathie c'est très vendeur la
sympathie surtout auprès des enfants il
y a le billet d'autorité l'uniforme ça
les marques de dentifrice elles ont bien
compris je vous avais dit on commence
doucement mais on pourrait aller
beaucoup plus loin à faire de l'étude de
cas par exemple je pourrais même vous
parler de l'étude du parcours de votre
regard sur une publicité visuelle ça
dépendra de de vous et de comment vous
poussez cette vidéo merci à Odou
d'ailleurs pour la collaboration
commerciale en début de vidéo je
m'appelle toujours Fabien OLC à très
bientôt Ciao